starting out as a young Chef my biggest
influence was definitely French cuisine
and when I was 23 years of age I was
determined to learn as much as I could
so I set off for Paris to work in some
of the most demanding and exacting
kitchens in the world and my passion and
love for French food really took hold
first up for breakfast a French
Patisserie delicacy madelaines those
shells of a light sponge flavored with
lemon and poppy seed
for lunch my take on a French classic
the salad nicoise with a gutsy Caper and
anchovy dressing
accompanied by delicious pear and creamy
goat cheese Tartine
and my youngest Tilly gets a taste for
French cooking as we create chicken
fricassee
so with Herbie sauteed potatoes followed
by lavender creme caramel this is my
ultimate French food breakfast lunch and
dinner my ultimate French breakfast
isn't complex or flashy it's just simple
elegant and delicious
the secret to a really good Madeleine is
it's light fluffy delicious and it's
perfect
with the coffee in the morning so melt
the butter gently next
three eggs
[Music]
that was one of the most exciting things
about living in Paris there was always
something there and that little pastry
shop that I used to live above I'm gonna
incorporate the sugar
and then give that a really good whisk
because it's important to incorporate
some air now the secret to whisking is a
big beautiful balloon whisk
the bigger the balloon whisk the more
aeration you'll get in the mixture so
the best thing to do
let's just go from left to right and
then change hands
every 15 or 20 seconds
so your hands never get tired and tilt
the ball to your advantage as well
now you can see the mixture starting to
Aeries
it's almost double in size
[Music]
the more you whisk this the lighter it
becomes
so it starts to almost look like a light
whipped cream
gone as that dark Rich egg yolk color
beautiful
once the eggs and sugar become pale
creamy and thick sift in the
self-raising flour
sieve in the flour
now I'm giving my madeleines a Twist by
adding poppy seeds for a crunch and
lemon for flavor a zest of a lemon in
there
generous on the lemon
lime is wonderful
orange zest again beautiful I've even
made pink grapefruit madeleines with
poppy seeds delicious
but lemon for me is the best
pour the melted butter down the side of
the bowl
so it cools down even more and then
combine start mixing that in
it's really important at this stage that
we don't beat
the mixture I want to keep that nice
aerated texture across the Madeleine mix
so I'm going to use a spatula now and
just gently mix my butter in
now give that a good mix
and they say that the longer you make
the mix up in advance
higher they raise in the oven
look at that
it looks beautiful leave that to sit
there
[Music]
and we'll butter and line our molds
you can make these in little miniature
Yorkshire pudding molds I've even seen
madeleines being cooked in espresso cups
so if you haven't got the traditional
Madeleine tray Yorkshire pudding trays
are just as good lightly butter
the inside of the tree take a tablespoon
of flour
and the secret now is to line the mold
with the flour that stops any chance of
the Madeleine is sticking
tap the sieve
into all the little grooves
and this will ensure that they'll come
out instantly
then all you do then is just stand up
the tray and tap it two or three times
and you'll see the flower roll out
so there you go
the baking sheet lined beautifully no
excess butter and no excess flour the
beauty of this recipe is that you can
make it the night before and then simply
bake it in the morning
when you're ready to go put the mixture
into a jug to make it really easy to
pour into the tin
give it a little stir
so you've got that nice even
distribution of those poppy seeds
and just gently
lovely
firm up to the top oh beautiful
so much easier pouring this from a jug
because you get the exact amount in in
the oven 180 degrees do not open that
door before 10 minutes
and wait for that wonderful surprise
[Music]
I smell amazing
now
a little tap on the side of the tray
and to just all pop out it's usually
done
that smell is unique
that nice soft
crisp outside with this lovely fragrant
fluffy Center
and the secret of a great Madeleine
as the French would swear by it there's
this lovely little Mound on top
they call it the nipple
but
that is the confirmation that is perfect
my poppy and lemon madeleines are a
sophisticated content will start to the
day and take me straight back to Paris
[Music]
coming up I'll be showing you a
fantastic French inspired lunch and
dinner
[Music]
but first here's a look at some of the
key ingredients you'll need to add a bit
of garlic Flair to your cooking
[Music]
the one ingredient most associated with
French food is garlic and it's no
surprise almost every one of my French
recipes has it in
[Music]
garlic is a member of the allium or
onion family and comes in all shapes and
sizes and strengths Pink garlic from
lautrec in Southwest France is
considered the finest with a strong
sweet taste
elephant garlic has massive bulbs and a
much milder flavor but today I'm using a
common white type you get in all the
supermarkets it's a great all-rounder
[Music]
Brandy really is the ultimate Spirit of
France it's made from either distilled
grapes or fruit
armenyak from gascony in the Southwest
is made from wine distilled in Oak casks
and it's the oldest recorded Brandy in
France
cognacs also are wine Brandy named after
town in Portugal region in the west
where it must be made to be classified
as cognac
Calvados is an apple brandy made from
distilled cider and comes from Normandy
French cooked with Brandy a lot and tend
to ignite or flombe it to bring amazing
depth of flavor to dishes like the
chicken fricassee I'm serving for dinner
France has justifiably famous for his
cheeses and one of my favorites is Ghost
cheese
called Chev in French they produce
hundreds of types from the very mild and
creamy to the strong and pungent and
because it's so delicious the French
keep most of it for themselves and only
export a tiny amount luxurious soft
ghost cheese goes perfectly well with
sweet pears and earthy walnuts in the
open sandwich I'm making for lunch
when I was living in France I got to
know two very distinct traditions of
French food on the one hand there was
the delicious oat Cuisine I cooked all
day in the restaurant and on the other
hand there was the food you ate in
people's homes which is a lot simpler to
make but still absolutely delicious
My ultimate French inspired lunch was
very light bright and really takes me
back to when I lived in Paris
it's my take on the salad nicoise to
serve with a delicious goat cheese and
pear Tartine
think of the nisoise as an assembly job
of delicious ingredients brought
together with a fantastic dressing the
secret behind mine salad niswas is in
the dressing
spoon Dijon mustard into a pestle and
mortar some people top the salad with
Anchovies and capers but in mine they're
the base to the dressing we're going to
grind that to a paste
and then get the garlic in there season
well with black pepper
foreign
because of the anchovies add a couple
tablespoons of red wine vinegar olive
oil and lastly flat leaf parsley to give
the dressing freshness against those
deep flavors they say thick Rich
substantial dressing dressing done now
for the salad ball potatoes green beans
and eggs from a rolling ball seven and a
half to eight minutes it should keep
that nice yolky creamy texture in the
center once the eggs are ready put them
into cold water to stop them cooking and
this is a great trick to peel them so
much easier peeling eggs when you use
the water
but they've been cooling down in and the
water will seep underneath all the shell
and so the whole shell just gets peeled
off of one beautiful big layer
now beans
nice and crunchy season the beans and
potatoes whilst they're still warm so
they absorb more flavor a little drizzle
of olive oil salt pepper
and just let them sit there
whilst the potatoes and beans cool down
I'm doing a simple French Open sandwich
which is called a Tartine
it's a delicious
first I'm toasting baguette on the
griddle
lightly oil
a griddle pan get your bread
stick it on there
take a pair
it goes brilliantly well with goat's
cheese slice the pear into finger width
pieces
the color we're looking for that dark
crispy texture now for the ghost cheese
give it a season it doesn't need salt
because little Fresco's cheese is
already quite salty then a handful of
crumbled walnuts
they go under the grill whilst I put the
tuning these ones together
my secret to assembling a great nicoise
salad is the start of the middle of the
plate and add ingredients layer by layer
so there's one thing I'm always missing
the bottom of salad is dressing so I
like to put it on the plate first baby
gem lettuce is great because it's robust
and holds that heavy dressing then add
firm waxy salad potatoes and green beans
I like them to have a bit of a crunch
canned tuna can be fantastic I'm using a
good quality one in olive oil which has
been drained next baby plum tomatoes
which have a lovely intense sweet flavor
and then my eggs that nice dark Rich
yolk beautiful
yoga still creamy
inside
he's a little Olive nisoise this will
work just as well with other black
olives and then the dressing
drizzle that round gently beautiful
that is a nisswas in heaven now Tartine
wow just a smell
of those grilled walnuts
that is beautiful
a simple but very elegant
tuna nisswas
but delicious ghost cheese sandwich
[Music]
my vibrant and gutsy nicoise salad with
that incredible anchovy and Caper
dressing so with a pear and goat cheese
Tartine too good to let the French keep
it all to themselves
in general I think it's pretty fair to
say that whether they're rich or poor
the French are a nation of food
obsessives and one of the biggest
lessons I absorb when I was over there
was the central importance of great
ingredients
I'm not the only one in my family who
loves French food
joining me in the kitchen today is my
youngest daughter Tilly who adores it
made with fantastic chicken cooked using
a classic but simple French technique
this is my ultimate home-cooked French
dinner first chop my chicken fricassee
Tilly
do you mind helping daddy with the
chicken fricassee please
we're going to start off with Browning
oh
the chicken off nicely pan on get that
nice and hot what I want you to do for
me first is to season
chicken with salt and pepper please
thank you so that's on one side then we
turn the chicken over
so we season it on the other side
salt good girl and pepper nice
now this is almost like a chicken stew
okay what's that there
[Music]
Thai time good girl what's that one
there
that's right Rosemary
and because this is quite a rustic
French dish we don't need to chop
everything so you get the garlic
and you just smash it like that now
smell
that's right
so that's nice and hot put a tablespoon
of olive oil in there a couple of gloves
one two good girl put the chicken in
it and you lay away
you get that nice and brown getting good
at this you are
inside down so we get the color on the
skin now I just want you to cut the
mushrooms in half the belly please okay
these are Chestnut mushrooms there are
lots of different types of mushrooms out
there there are lots and lots of
different types of mushrooms which one's
your favorite one of my favorites is the
Giro mushroom I like mushrooms that are
a bit bigger than this and
um some dinners with mum we cut out the
middle put pesto and cheese in it and
then we bake them oh so I want you to
sprinkle the pancetta over the chicken
please
here we go nice the machine did not yet
because I'm gonna get some color on the
chicken first
okay
and as that pancetta
started to cook down to put a really
nice flavor on the chicken yeah yeah so
we're sort of soaking everything okay
like garlic in please good girl just
throw them in
and I want you to sprinkle the mushrooms
on top of that good girl
and then there's a rosemary you can get
your fingers like that and you pull it
down you take it all off
hold it
hold it put it down good cow so now
you've got the nice little Rosemary
sprigs and we do the same with the thyme
now the thyme flower is a little bit
smaller what different flavors do they
give so the thyme is a little bit
sweeter okay and the Rosemary a little
bit more Savory which ones you like I
like them both because they both give a
nice smell don't they so they Leaf in
I'd like you to put that Rosemary and
Thyme in there please
[Music]
sprinkle over right I'd like you to
stand back now because we're going to
flambe this I do not want to get those
little slippers caught on fire what are
their names
and Judith Judith nice okay great ready
yeah him with a brandy
and then just tilt the pan gently
whoa whoa how cool is that
beautiful a bit like a cauldron oh the
cognac has been flambe so there's no raw
alcohol anywhere so we've got a really
nice deep rich flavor I'm gonna add my
chicken stock you know Rumple likes that
not my slipper
ah Rumple it up well he likes chicken
stock yes when he's a good boy he gets
him he gets it in his um with his
biscuit it's gone and like wow really
quickly simmer and reduce the stock for
around 10 minutes now we're gonna cook
the most amazing potatoes
so do potatoes are really simple to make
and absolutely delicious start by
slicing the potatoes into finger whipped
pieces then parboil them for five to six
minutes
when you cook something like Rosemary or
thyme or basil because it slowly let off
the flavor into the hot roll very much
so
pan add a tablespoon of goose fat and
saute the potatoes until they turn
golden
and add in shallots garlic Rosemary and
Thyme that goes in
over top
and that goose fat now is starting to
fry the potatoes you just leave that sap
there
to complete my ultimate French dinner my
version of a classic a glorious lavender
creme caramel for dessert
the first job is the lavender sugar you
can buy this ready-made or simply add
dried edible sprigs of lavender to
caster sugar and store you can also try
this trick with vanilla pods and
cinnamon to bring new subtle flavors to
sweets and bacon
[Music]
for the creme caramel melt plain caster
sugar until it turns dark golden
pour into ramekins sprinkle with
lavender flowers and cool
now to make a simple custard gently heat
whole milk in a pan until steaming
meanwhile whisk together egg vanilla
seeds and lavender sugar until golden
and fluffy then gradually pour the hot
milk into the mix whisking continuously
until the custard is smooth and creamy
set cook in a water bath or bammari a
good tip is to line a roasting tin with
a cloth to stop the ramekins jiggling
around pour your custard
then boiling water around the ramekins
until halfway up the sides then cook in
a preheated oven for around 30 minutes
until set
cool in the fridge then when you're
ready to serve dip the ramekins in hot
water to loosen the creme caramel
[Music]
caramel
foreign
look at that chicken now
so I'm just going to turn the gas right
down
and put the lid on
just like that but leave a little bit so
it can let out some stuff so I can let
out some steam that's right
now what I'd like to do is to chop Deli
some parsley crunch it up nicely tuck
your fingers in and take your time
[Music]
now my hands have got lots of different
names they've got all those wonderful
flavors you could almost be French
sprinkle it on there
good girl
nice
messy bookoo
nice
no potatoes of chicken I can tell Jack's
gonna love this is he looks delish
doesn't it
before you took the lid off let's get on
my darling good job by the way thank you
I can't wait for the others to try it I
hope they love it this is my ultimate
French dinner chicken fricassee with
Sensational Herbie soda potatoes and
lavender creme caramel
[Music]
mom and Holly oh so nice doesn't it
no Daddy who's the one that burnt the
garlic what
could you dad
trust you to find that Jack potatoes
he'll eat like these ones
oh no way
potatoes I love burnt garlic
Bon Appetit and look out for the burnt
garlic it was supposed to be crispy but
you've known the difference between
crispy and burnt do you know what I
think your daughter might take off to
you
hi sous chef cheers there are loads more
great home cooking recipes on my app
cook with me you can find it in the App
Store good luck
[Applause]
next time
okay today's all about healthy food I'm
going to show you that eating well and
eating healthily can go hand in hand I'm
a chef so my whole day not just meal
times is devoted to food if I'm not
cooking it I'm tasting it or thinking
about it my other great Passion life is
Fitness I've run over 10 marathons in
the last 10 years I have to get these
two sides of my life to work together
so get ready for my ultimate healthy
recipes dishes that are good for you
without any compromise on flavor to
start a fresh and fruity breakfast to
set you up for the day quick Birch and
muesli you can make in minutes next a
liquid lunch which is generally healthy
glorious gazpacho soup followed by a
wafer thin pineapple capacho for dessert
for dinner it's my youngest daughter
Tilly joining me in the kitchen to cook
up a simple meal packed with goodness
teriyaki salmon filled with Amiga oils
and superfood soba noodle salad
for dessert a delicious light and fizzy
Spritz jelly he would say done this is
my ultimate healthy food breakfast lunch
and dinner first up is my breakfast
Bircher muesli
Bertram usually traditionally gets made
the night before and left in the fridge
I find that a little bit too heavy and
slightly stodgy so it's the same
principles but a lot lighter first in
the yogurt I think live and raw milk
yogurt are best they're packed with
calcium enzymes and probiotics which
help your body absorb nutrients
it's interesting
because the kids especially would prefer
their muesli with milk but the yogurt
it's so much better for them I like
making it literally 10 minutes before I
want to serve it
because it doesn't become stodgy yogurt
in apple juice has a great way of
sweetening I'm usually a couple
tablespoons in
give that a little mix
now
sprinkle in the oats
I like putting two thirds in now to
absorb an almost double in size and the
last third of oats in at the end oats
are low on the glycemic index which
means they slowly release energy to keep
you going right through to lunch I quite
like it when it just falls off the spoon
you can see literally in seconds it's
got thicker
the rest of the oats in
so I've got different textures now mix
that up nicely
and it literally takes three or four
minutes to put together
it's gonna get a dry pan on
one's incredibly healthy toasting them
even better flavor
flake them into the pan lightly toast
them
that gives a really nice sort of crunch
to the top of the museum
[Music]
roll them around the pan so they're
evenly toasted
out into a bowl
the exciting thing about putting your
own music together is that you're in
control blackberries summer raspberries
strawberries and so it changes berries
don't just taste great they're packed
with antioxidants and vitamin C and K so
just Dot
the top of your muesli with your
blackberries generous on the
blackberries
sweetness tartness
acidic
and then just sprinkle over
your nice almonds
I quite like a lot of crunch on top
so be generous
that looks fantastic
perfect way
to start the day
my quick Birch of muesli doesn't just
taste incredible it makes you feel
fantastic it's my ultimate healthy
breakfast there really is no better way
to start the day
[Music]
next I'm putting the flavor back into
healthy food with a sensational lunch
and dinner
here are the key ingredients you'll need
to cook them
[Music]
first on my ultimate shopping list are
soba noodles these gray brown noodles
are made from buckwheat so they're
gluten free and high in protein
they're quick to cook and so versatile
use them in stir fries soups and salads
like the one I'm making for dinner
salmon fillets are brimming with super
healthy Amiga oils and so quick and
versatile to cook whether poached
grilled pan-fried baked or quickest of
all raw or sushi I'm making a family
favorite for my healthy dinner teriyaki
salmon
pomegranates have been revered since
ancient Greek and Egyptian times for
healing properties today we know these
little Jewels are packed with
antioxidants minerals and vitamins b c e
and K they are fantastic and Middle
Eastern dishes or scattered over fruit
salads like the fine pineapple Carpaccio
I'm making for lunch
I don't believe in fatty diets and diet
foods there's no cardboard tasting rice
cakes in our house let me tell you at
its simplest healthy eating for me is
all about fresh home-cooked food portion
control and a balanced diet and it
should be a pleasure to eat you should
never turn meal times into something you
dread for my ultimate healthy lunch I'm
showing you all my favorite dishes it's
packed with vitamins and goodness but
it's also super tasty gazpacho
for dessert sweet and refreshing
pineapple like you've never tasted
before first job the gazpacho soup for
me the secret of a great gazpacho is
over ripe tomatoes Peppers cucumber a
little bit of heat with a garlic we've
got to leave it to marinade first
Peppers cut around the flat edges to
minimize waste
then chop the nice thing about
making the gazpacho there's no set
recipe because you can put it together
purely all tomatoes
half Peppers half tomatoes
I like the flavor of the cucumber in
there as well that gives it that
freshness
The Secret of a great dispatcher is the
longer you leave it marinating
the better the flavor
so if you can get this done the night
before and left in the fridge
the results are stunning the green and
red peppers have subtly complementary
flavors and go well with ripe Tomatoes
start off by removing the better core a
little knife
and just put it in where the core is and
twist it round and you get this little
core out I remember my first experience
eating a gazpacho in Spain
mind-blowing I've never forgotten that
quarter your Tomatoes keeping the juicy
seeds that add so much depth of taste
nice then from there cucumber just peel
that the seeds I'm Gonna Leave in
that gives it the flavor
and the texture cucumber and gazpacho
does exactly what it does in a pims it
sort of freshens it up
a massive mouth watering slice that in
half
again
into quarters and chop
now to give gazpacho its unique texture
and thicken the soup bread and the
crispy the crust the better then garlic
thinly sliced
next spring onions nice and roughly
chopped
and basil stalks and all we can use
stalks and basil stalks parsley stalks
tarragon stalks they have the most
amazing flavor basil and
and now I'm going to start marinating
salt black pepper and a good coating of
olive oil this gives it a glossy creamy
flavor
and the Cherry vinegar that's the
perfect vinegar
for the gazpacho it's a strong acidic
complement to the flavors
then just mix it up and smell already
it's incredible
it doesn't look
like a gazpacho but by the time this
marinades all those flavors start
getting to know one another
all of a sudden you've got this huge
explosion of contrast
now
push that down in the restaurants we
press the marinade down overnight a
couple of big pans on top and we Crush
all the ingredients and then Blitz it
the next day
flavor is extraordinary leave all those
fresh ingredients packed with goodness
to marinade from half an hour to even
overnight and then when you blend it it
just comes together like this Sumptuous
Rich delicious chilled soup to go with
my super tasty soup I've got an ultra
healthy and exciting dessert capaccio of
pineapple which is a Chevy way of saying
super thinly sliced it's done with a
Twist
we're gonna have a delicious flavored
salt has to be flavored with vanilla
simply scrape out the vanilla seeds and
add to sea salt along with the Pod to
store now that basically keeps forever
there's no sale by date because it's
salt and vanilla so
so fragrant so delicious you don't need
much of this fragrance salt to intensify
the sweetness of the pineapple
the pineapple
[Music]
sliced peeled pineapple into wafer thin
pieces it's almost a nice little discs
slightly transparent
[Music]
once you've sliced the pineapple take
the flavor to another level
a light sprinkle of vanilla salt and
arrange the pineapple in a flower shape
[Music]
beautiful way of finishing
a meal
fragrance
other than the crunch
with the salt
and the vinegar salt just marinades
the pineapple beautifully then scatter
nutrient-rich pomegranate seeds over the
top to finish finely shredded fresh mint
just
slicing
really thin and then that'll give that
nice cool minty flavor
a pineapple
my Carpaccio is ready and my gazpacho
has been marinating in the fridge time
to blend the soup
in
foreign
ER
start off nice and slowly
blend until super fine and gloriously
silky and serve refreshingly cold
get your bowl
and pour it in
now to finish it get some fresh basil
roll it nice and tight
shred it
and then drop it into your bowl
fresh
chopped basil and then finally
just a touch of extra virgin olive oil
just to give that really nice additional
freshness
and look at that healthy and delicious
gazpacho soup to me is a taste of
Mediterranean sunshine in a bowl
followed by the way for thin Carpaccio
of pineapple with jewels of pomegranate
goodness for dessert
practically all of your five a day in
one incredible healthy lunch
a healthy diet is an important one but
we're pretty relaxed about it my
philosophy is simple try and eat less of
the bad stuff and eat more of the good
stuff and joining me in the kitchen is
my netball nut youngest Tilly for dinner
it's a mega Rich teriyaki salmon with a
buckwheat soba noodle salad brimming
with healthy greens and a light upper
roll Spritz jelly for dessert first job
the teriyaki marinade for the salmon
silly
gonna help Daddy with a salmon please
right
Teriyaki delicious
sticky sweet salmon okay first of all
I'd like you
a little season on the salmon please
with salt and pepper thank you
all right I want you to slice the garlic
one in front two behind yep
oh oh get a bit faster in the old age
huh good girl
thank you right garlic in with the
ginger
so we're gonna make a marinade
okay do you know what a marinade is it's
what you coat something in that's right
so let's start off with
soy sauce three tablespoons one good two
two three this is rice wine also known
as mirin
one in
I know what that is that's maple syrup
is it like
beautiful and a little touch of olive
oil
it smells really good I want you to rub
salmon in the marinade if you get chance
to do this the night before the salmon
actually changes color but it's fine
even with 10 or 15 minutes before you
start cooking it does the ginger and
garlic give it a different
do you know what it helps improve the
taste when we cook it I have this really
nice glaze on there okay right let's put
that in the fridge to marinade and we'll
start the jellies
to follow the teriyaki salmon a grown-up
light dessert Prosecco an aperol Spritz
jelly
start by soaking gelatine sheets in cold
water
poor Prosecco 100 milliliters of water
and caster sugar into the pan heat until
the sugar is dissolved then add your
gelatin sheets
leave the mix to cool top up with more
Prosecco and a dash of the Bittersweet
Italian aperol
[Music]
then pour into tumblers over orange
slices and leave to set in the fridge
all the refreshment of a spritz in a
perfect jelly form
the Teriyaki Salmon's marinating time to
get on with the noodle and vitamin
packed veg and seed salad
noodles why are they this color now this
color because they're made out of
Buckwheat
okay and then we're gonna drop them in
so nice and careful if you slide them
that way
and then you go like that in your hand
and then we'll show you there
and then look
hold them like that and drop them into
the pan okay got them yeah okay so hold
on tight off we go
nice do they take longer to cook than
normal noodles actually take literally
five minutes now what are they
really crunchy now
carrot
and kale
I'm going to show you a really quick way
of slicing carrot ribbons so you just
come down
um
that's right off you go there we go
nice big long ribbons
sugar snap peas in yeah okay into the
noodles
got two
oh thank you wake up daddy next
kale now you know how good that is for
you right yeah kale in right how the
ribbons
they're good oh that's nice
you okay like some salt and pepper on
your little bit carrot
ribbons go in
good girl I didn't forget any like you
did excuse me and because we've shaved
them really thinly like this
how long do you think they're going to
take to cook
about a minute
does it look yummy doesn't it now we're
going to drain
the noodles
that is beautiful see how the kales go
what happens if you cook um the
vegetables for too long would they just
go a bit hard they'll go soft and mushy
okay
and then we're gonna drop the noodles
then
now
I'm gonna make those noodles taste even
better I'd like you to put a little bit
of salt and pepper on there for me
please
next
chop
spring onions straight wash your fingers
please
I'm gonna put a dressing on there Ginger
goes in I can smell that from there you
can Count Me
how nice is that gonna be like a
multi-season salad isn't it yeah
smell
um Sesame oh yeah that's right sesame
oil a touch or sesame oil over
okay rice wine vinegar a little splash
okay and then finally
and it will touch
soy sauce so that you drizzle that in
please
that's it
one little final
ingredient what's that seaweed whose
favorite is that Jack's Holly's and my
slice it into strips
okay I'm gonna chop that
oh how is that good I want you to
sprinkle that on top of the noodles
but I'll squeeze the lemon juice
oh excuse me
I also had a lemon shower today
souvenoodle salad is ready now
we'll get on and cook the salmon
oh it looks good doesn't it
boom let's go
right pan nice and hot
what did I show you when you put fish in
the pan which way did you put in
he puts it in um skin down that's right
and then there's the pan there and you
put it in there and you lay away from
you if you lay it towards you what
happens it will spit at you it will
Splash that's right so take your time
good girl
here we go
and the last one good girl very slippy
very slippy
it's not so fresh nice
nice a nice little bit of Ginger on
there now a little bit of garlic it
smells of a mixture of all the flavors
there's color on the salmon
[Music]
that's right
I'm gonna like you to pour the rest of
marinade over for me please
nice okay
Now The Summer's gonna glaze now well
done you're getting good at this cooking
stuff you know that would you like to be
a chef when you grow up yeah really
would you like to have your own
restaurant one day I'd like to have a
bakery a bakery me and Jack are planning
on opening one together oh and you do
the paninis and make the coffees and I
do the cakes and the cookies then it's
gonna have like scrambled eggs for
breakfast so you've already thought this
out yeah we were planning it the other
night and when we couldn't sleep and
who's gonna be the head chef and who's
gonna be the sous chef no we're not
gonna do that because we've both got
different rolls in it oh I see this is
well thought out yeah but there's We're
not gonna need anybody else apart from
me and him so no other people that was
nice it sounds amazing
you got the spoon here like this okay
and just tilt the pan I'll tilt the pan
you glaze the salmon point please
now
very my darling uh ready I'm ready
do you keep the ginger on top of it
what was your favorite type of salmon
when you were little
salmon fish cakes
oh I like those you like those
how does that look that looks delicious
I'd like you to carry that very
carefully over to the table okay and
I'll carry your noodles ready
let's go well done
so I'm fascinated with this restaurant
you and Jack are going to open yeah
this is my ultimate healthy dinner it's
fresh home-cooked and full of goodness
but most importantly it's absolutely
delicious
[Music]
holy mum
so we have a delicious turkey salmon
with sober noodles
look and sound super healthy
I think we did well high five Mickey
would say done boom thank you
there are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app cook with me you can
find it in the App Store good luck